ça s'appelle aussi dégradation bien
public
vous ne connaissez peut-être pas les
tagueurs mais vous avez sûrement vu leur
trace c'est graffiti qui recouvre les
murs du métro ou d'ailleurs ce sont
leurs signatures alors vandalisme pour
les uns œuvre d'art pour les autres en
tout cas c'est graffiti coûtent cher
Ambroise pain a rencontré certains de
leurs auteurs
moi je me prends moi je me sens comme un
homeboy si tu vois ce que ça veut dire
j'écoute durable je tape je fais des
graves je veux des mecs qui sont dans le
mouvement c'est cool je suis pas un
zoulou Spark
c'est un peu comme une signature et une
phrase que bah c'est ce qu'on peut
appeler de l'art 2000 à Paris dans les
bandes des fils de bonne famille et de
moins bonne la casquette c'est
l'anti-bérée français moyen le ceinturon
c'est la consécration du nom certaines
marques de basket sont boycotées car
vendues en Afrique du Sud c'est on
saccage les premières classes
bon c'est c'est pour le poulet c'est
pour bien montrer que nous première
classe et deuxième classe et aucune
différence quoi et c'est mieux d'être en
second classe de nos jours qu'être en
première classe quoi c'est plus propre
la mairie de Paris a effacé 100000
mètres carrés de graffiti l'an passé et
la RATP a dépensé 35 millions de francs
il y a deux ans elle avait parié
l'élimination de tous les tags les
tagueurs adorent les défis ils ont osé
depuis bon bah plus ça va et plus il y a
de Tiger qui se forment à Paris quoi
le plus beau tac aussi pour moi ce
serait
voyant du bas de des Champs-Élysées
sur un camion de la Comatec ou sur un
quart de police Pacifique
antimilitariste dans leur bombe il n'y a
que de la peinture le plus beau crime du
monde c'est un graffiti le plaisir de
retrouver sa marque sur un mur oublié
une affiche électorale est-ce vraiment
plus beau
ils ont pourtant un vrai scrupule la
couche d'ozone oui la destruction de la
couche d'ozone la peinture en aérosol ça
pollue
on les appelle les tagueurs la nuit il
rase les murs équipés de feu trou de
bons à peinture ils affectionnent les
wagons du métro ce ne sont plus des
graffitisent les amateurs c'est de
l'arbre brut peut-être mais chère pour
la RATP qui estime que le nettoyage lui
coûte quelque 35 millions de francs par
an Agnès Poirier et Bernie Mériaux se
sont fondus dans la nuit pour les suivre
le dernier train vient de passer la nuit
leur appartient
c'est le grand frisson attention danger
d'abord signaler son passage marqué son
territoire alors on tag c'est-à-dire on
signe illisible pour tous les initiés
reconnaîtront et puis ils attaquent la
fraise la brûlure comme il disent leur
signature stylisée et un personnage qui
seront vu des lobes par des dizaines de
milliers de banlieusards
du jeu c'est
qu'on nous voit un peu partout et qu'on
arrive à percer parce que bon la plupart
d'entre nous ont envie de passer un peu
ça s'appelle aussi dégradation bien
public
[Applaudissements]
la chasse au graphiteurs est ouverte
ras-le-bol des tags qui défigurent les
stations et ceux il les trains
affirme-t-on à la SNCF et à la RATP et
l'on annonce plus de répression et plus
de nettoyage
j'ai donné un chiffre qui est le chiffre
de 10 millions de nouveaux francs bien
entendu que nous avons dépensé l'année
dernière en 1988 pour faire du nettoyage
aussi bien les temps avec des guerres
mais c'est insuffisant puisque cette
année en 89 on voit bien que il faudra
dépenser beaucoup plus que ça
décourager les tagueurs mais ils sont
déjà partout Ramsès et Pupa sont passés
des graffitis à la musique ils ont créé
Saï Saï leur emblème c'est un tag ils
ont à peine 18 ans ils veulent que ce
qu'ils appellent leur art soient
respectés
quand tu te mets à jouer la musique ils
disent oh qu'est-ce que c'est que ce
bruit c'est pas du bruit c'est de la
musique ou bien qu'est-ce que c'est que
cette saloperie sur le mur c'est pas de
la saloperie c'est de la peinture
certains graffiteurs sont même très
demandé Olivier mégaeton par exemple il
peignait sur des palissades de chantier
aujourd'hui rebaptisés artiste aérosol
il décore des devantures de magasins et
à dessiner le graphisme de la carte
jeune
Darko lui n'a pas eu cette chance pour
avoir peint une fresque sur un pont de
la SNCF on lui réclame 750 000 francs de
dommages et intérêts je suis pas
conscient de d'être un délinquant parce
que je peins des murs même si je demande
pas aux propriétaires pour moi c'est pas
un délire
je ne cherche pas à détruire
vandale ou artiste que vont-ils devenir
la prison peut être pas certains d'entre
eux sont déjà dans les galeries d'art
[Musique]